Last question today. Hey David, why do some
of these foreigners on Youtube obsess about
American politics?
I'm thinking of Sargon of a cod and Steven
Crowder. Why aren't they talking about the
politics in their country instead of riding
the wave and talking about American politics?
Well, you answered your own question. Riding
the wave. Uh, so the people that are being
referred to Sargon have a cod is a British
gentleman who, who is actually named Carl.
I know him was Carl Benjamin, but he goes
by star gun of a cod. He's British. He talks
a lot about American politics. That's true.
Steven Crowder I believe is is American by
birth, but he mostly grew up in Canada. The
question about whether he's really more Canadian
or American is more of an academic one than
a that are real important here and now question,
but the question sort of answers itself, which
is a lot of the countries that, uh, speak
English, um, are much less interesting politically,
internationally.
This doesn't mean that they don't have interesting
internal politics. Canadian politics matter
a lot to Canadians. British politics matter
a lot to folks in the United Kingdom. But
this is a money grab and it's a way to get
attention, right? I mean, you talk about American
politics, the United States has 340 million
people who live here or however many. This
is a relatively wealthy country, so if people
want to support your commentary on American
politics, they are more able to do so. In
terms of income, and I'm not talking about
just the countries, Canada, UK and the u s
there are more people all over the world that
are interested in American politics than are
in Canadian politics or British politics.
So they're doing what's going to get attention.
I also, I mean quite frankly, if, if I lived
in Argentina and I did a show, I was born
in Argentina, that's the relevance.
I don't think I'd be doing a show about American
politics. I do a show about American politics
because this is where I live and I'm most
in touch with with what's going on politically
here and it affects me in a much more direct
way than it would to do politics of whatever
other place if I lived somewhere else. It
doesn't seem that interesting to me to follow
the politics of the United States and do a
show about it. So you really have to ask them.
I know that, uh, Carl has been asked, uh,
why does he talk so much about Trump? Maybe
I don't even remember, remember what he said?
I haven't seen one of his videos for a long
time. I actually am unsure if he's even still
on Youtube. I know he was kicked off of some
platforms. I don't even know. Uh, it's really
a question for them, but to me it's just that
it's the audience.
You get much more attention talking about
American politics than you do about Canadian
or, or British politics on a global level.
Within those countries. There are lots of
popular domestic policy programs and I think
they're just going where the money and the
attention, it's proved me wrong. If it's something,
if there's some other reason, then I'd love
to hear it. And if they're just going to say,
well, American politics is agenda setting
globally. So even in another country, you're
still very much effected by American policy.
Okay. I mean, I guess this is kind of a, it
feels like a very mush mealy mouth, a milk
toast response, but okay. That, that can be
part of it. Let me know what you think explains
the focus on American politics by so many
foreign youtubers and online
personalities. We've got a great bonus show
for you today. Get access to the bonus show
instantly by becoming a member or a patient.
The David Pakman show@davidpacman.com.